- This is it, I'm going
on a date with Eric Andre.
- So what's up?
Chug that wine.
It's time for you to chug that wine.
Chug, chug, chug, chug,
chug, chug, chug, chug, chug,
yes, round two baby boy.
- I'm really excited to
on a date with Eric Andre.
I think he's a really unique guy.
- What's the farthest you ever got?
Are you a Jew?
Let's 69.
- What?
- I don't know a god
damn thing about Keith.
Yeah, that was pretty good.
- Do you like me?
- I like you a lot better.
(slow paced music)
- I got you these.
- Thanks.
Now can I eat these
before the meal comes out.
- I mean it's up to you, Eric.
Whatever you wanna do.
How are you?
- I'm gonna get wet, I wanna
get my butt cheeks all wet.
- I don't wanna start
out the day like that.
We need to get to know each other.
- Why not dude, it's 2016.
What's going on with you?
- [Keith] I'm just on a date with you.
- Loosen up, you're making me nervous.
- I am nervous.
- Well I got Ebola.
- That is concerning.
- How do you feel about that?
- Concerned.
- And I'm gonna fill you up.
- Don't fill me up.
- With my virus, to the top.
Like god damn soft serve ice cream.
- [Keith] Do you want some wine, Eric?
- I would love some.
(upbeat music)
- I'm excited to just sort
of let our emotions flow
and get to know each other, and who knows,
maybe we fall in love.
- I have a very tiny penis,
I have a micro penis.
Looks like a second belly button.
- I don't think that's true.
I mean I don't think
that a measure of a man
should be measured by
the measure of his penis.
- Well wait until you see my dick,
'cause it is embarrassing.
- I hope that we can act
on a really deep level,
and I hope that he can
see in me what I think
is valuable about me as a partner.
- I haven't planned
anything romantic for Keith.
I am unprepared.
I am very nervous.
It's time for you to chug that wine.
Chug, chug, chug, chug,
chug, chug, chug, chug.
- So we're half way through the date.
- Round two baby boy.
Chug, chug, chug.
- [Keith] I'm much drunker
than I thought I'd be here.
- Waiter, fill us up.
- But I think the date's going well.
(talking over each other)
- And then I won't make you chug anymore.
- Eric, Eric.
I think he likes me.
I think we're actually
connecting as people.
- 60 seconds on the clock.
- When I finish this,
we're gonna have sushi.
- In three, two, one,
chug, chug, chug, chug,
chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug,
chug, chug, chug, chug, chug.
- He thinks he has the upper hand.
He does.
- You know, this restaurant I would figure
it would have a better presentation
for people dining in.
- Well we're, yeah we're
obviously at a different place.
- You're slurring your words.
It's starting to worry me.
- [Keith] Why would it worry you?
- Can you fill up the wine?
- No, please don't.
Eric this isn't going
how I wanted it to go.
- What are you talking
about, we're hitting it off.
- I don't know, I just never
know where I stand with you.
(sighs)
I drank a lot of wine.
He kept insisting that I drink wine
and I wanted to prove to him
that I was the kind of
person he wanted to be with.
Tell me about your mom.
- My mom's great.
- Cool, did she ever sing
you a song that you remember?
Could you sing it?
- I swear to God I'm not making this up.
My mom, when I would cry when I was little
she used to sing me,
♫ Oh my little shmoiken boiken
♫ Oh my little boiken shmoiken
♫ Doiken boiken moiken
And she would just freestyle Yiddish.
Boiken means a little boy,
but beyond that it was gibberish.
- He sang the song that
his mom sang to him.
I mean that's crazy.
You were a music major.
You played base, then you
switched out of it, gave it up.
I was a french horn major, I gave it up.
- Let's see you play french horn.
- Patrick, can I have
my french horn please?
- Fantastic, I did not know that,
that was gonna happen like that.
- I'm gonna qualify this
performance with the fact
that I haven't played in seven years.
So I brought out the horn,
I didn't have anything prepared,
but I just let my emotion push me through
what I would play for him.
(french horn blaring)
(emotional music)
- That was actually pretty good.
- [Keith] Not terrible.
- I think I love Keith.
- [Keith] Do you wanna get out of here?
- Yes, desperately.
- I know that you get
hurt a lot on your show.
You break the set everyday.
- Oh were you about to intro the massages?
- Yeah.
- But you wanted to be organic.
- So I probably shouldn't
have mentioned that.
- No, it's okay.
- I should act like it's a surprise.
- Yeah.
- A couples massage?
- Surprised?
- Thank you!
- [Keith] Well why don't
we put on some robes.
- You're blocking my shot.
- [Keith] God dammit.
- I'm sure that's what you want.
- Wait, where's the wine?
Chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug,
chug, chug, yeah baby.
- So we're gonna get massages,
and we're gonna keep talking
and then we're gonna decide
if you love me or not.
Stop using your dick to hit the robe.
YOu're kind of all over the place huh?
- Yeah, no shit dude.
Have you ever fucking seen me before?
- I've seen you before.
- I'm a fucking sassy little Kathy.
(laughing)
- In the massage, I tried
to dig deep into who he was.
'Cause so often interviewers
ask the surface level questions
and I wanted to really penetrate him.
I wanted to really penetrate him.
I really wanted to penetrate him.
Are you happy?
- Yeah, you already asked me that.
- I know, but if you're really happy,
then why are you always
trying to fuck with people?
- You think that's a sign
of depression or something?
- I don't know, if you need
to take down other people.
- I don't gotta take down anybody.
I'm trying to uplift people.
- [Keith] Yeah?
- [Eric] Yeah.
- [Keith] And how do you do that?
- I make people laugh.
- There was a moment where we very clearly
were one person.
- I fell in love with Keith.
- [Keith] Do you see a future with me?
- Yes.
- At the end of the day, I
wanted a chance to break away.
I was wondering if you and I could maybe
get away from the cameras
for a second and just talk?
- Yeah, sure.
- Hey man, I just wanna say that I had
a really good time with you.
Eric please, Eric come here.
Just hug me, just hug me.
You could tell by the way he
was pacing back and forth,
he was really nervous 'cause
he wanted this to work.
Eric, Eric, you can't
keep walking over there.
And I really wanted it to work.
This will never work.
Don't hit me in the dick, please.
You can't try to seduce me like that
at the end of the video.
He and I, we shared a kiss.
(somber music)
We shared a kiss.
I know that you don't want this to end
and I don't want this
to end, but it has to.
You're busy, I'm busy.
- Yeah.
- The two of us really
bonded and I really think
that people know now what
it's like to date Eric Andre,
and I'm really lucky.
I'm really lucky.
(somber music)
- It was alright.
- That was the best damn kiss of my life.
I'll miss you forever, Eric Andre.
Until next time.
(glass shatters)
(somber music)
(upbeat music)